I'll never forget matter of fact it's
crazy we went to this concert Run DMC
with your dad yep I know I told my
friend Shannon this was
87 it was still together forever tour at
the Capitol Center we just got to
remember to be that cool sometime you
know what I mean like yeah they didn't
know even though what the rap was yeah
you know what I mean but they took us
and the whole time we're there I'm 14.
there's this row like just 18 19 year
old college girls right here and my
dad's just going hey girls this is my
son Ryan I'm like shut the dad he's
like it's Ryan right here
anyhow you guys think he's cute and
they're dying loud I'm like Dad shut up
Dad try to enjoy this concert you dick